[Music]
please welcome back to our show the very
funny Roy Wood jr. yeah let's start I've
got an argument with one of my friends
over who's the best superhero first of
all the answer is Captain America okay
he's the best superhero he has an
african-american sidekick
that's that trumps any other superhero
tracks Wolverine spider-man I don't care
who you pick Captain America is the only
superhero fighting evil and black
unemployment that is amazing respected
he has a black psychic as his name's the
Falcon he's portrayed by Anthony Mackie
and the Falcon he's got this jetpack and
he flies around he's wearing jeans first
of all he's dressed casually to fight
evil and that's cool if you don't know
Captain America's story this is why this
is so groundbreaking he eats he's a
white dude from the 1940s who
accidentally gets frozen they thaw him
out in present day and he goes right
back to fighting crime he didn't even
eat breakfast send little Jackson just
handed him a uniform and a shield he was
gold but a black sidekick he's a white
man from the 1940s and he didn't ask a
single question about desegregation
because he would have been justified
from waking from his 70-year nap with a
couple of questions as soon as you wake
up is a frozen white dude in the first
person you see a samuel l.jackson you
might get a little uncomfortable what's
in the room I need you for the Avengers
hey I don't take orders from your cons
the Falcon flies in a row leaf reset oh
my god you're flying are you black
people take me to the president
love the movies I love interacting with
the dude that rips the ticket he's the
last person you see before the film he's
serious about it theater tube to the
left no jokes no small talk tight pants
that's why they recruit for airport
security you know that right
but I respect to do because he does his
job with minimal interaction and we've
lost that in this country everybody
wants to be your friend
and buddy yet that's why it takes longer
to get off the phone with customer
service than it does to ask the one
question you had they get all sensitive
at the end of the call okay again my
name is Daniel only time I like customer
service is so insane you wanna call
customer service call your cell phone
company when you're no longer under
contract you want to feel like king for
a date you call them when that contract
is up and you just make up stuff listen
your store nobody vacuum I want vacuums
on a regular basis and the guy panics
down on the phone he doesn't want to
lose we appreciate you okay listen I'm
gonna transfer you to Keith okay for you
to Keith and customer retention that's
what they have the cell phone companies
the company's a division called customer
retention which is corporate gibberish
for the - kisses they kiss yes this is
an entire department dedicated to just
giving you free stuff so that you don't
miss gets on the phone he's efficient he
gets to the keyboard I'm checking your
file you are eligible for 500 and
equipment 200 and accessories I'm going
through and unlimited data does that
work out for you I was like yeah Thank
You Keith I appreciate that
I put home a dorm on Facebook we going
out for drinks we freeze
love Keith makes you wish you had to do
like Keith and your phone at all times
Dundas Ellis where were you last night
and don't say that you were out with
this guy because I called Scott's wife
and she said he was home at 8 o'clock
you know who comes home at 8 o'clock
men who love their women so if you're
gonna use Scott as a lie about where you
you know what no I have a better
question where are we as a couple
because we are a unit as a couple it
doesn't matter where you were last night
because you can go back there tonight
you can go back there tomorrow you can
go back there for the rest of your life
and I can be free to find someone that
appreciates me someone that loves me
someone that's willing to commit
someone's it's not afraid to build
something that matters someone that
won't leave me crying buy a telephone
and two o'clock in the morning wonder if
he whether or not you're safe I'm just
transfer you to Keith
in girlfriend retention breakdown alive
may have residual
[Music]
[Applause]